this week on the podcast an interview
and an announcement i have been waiting
for months to air to the public you know
when you have one of these secrets you
want to share with the world but you
have to keep it to yourself and then
it's finally out that's what's happening
this week on forward what we have been
working on for months the co-ceo of
forward party matt shinners joins us to
talk about what the heck we've been
doing
[Music]
hello everyone an historic week here at
ford with me is the co-ceo of the
forward party my longtime friend and
collaborator and colleague matt jenners
welcome matt everybody thanks for having
me andrew really excited to talk about
the uh the new forward party yes the new
forward party same as the old ford party
but very different
with with a lot of new friends and
colleagues uh so you've been working on
this for months and we're gonna get to
it but how the heck did you come to
recognize that we need a third party in
the united states you actually put it on
your law school application a million
years ago yeah way way back in the day
um i got into uh some some fights with
some democratic speakers at undergrad
about third parties being necessary for
the country and it started from a
different place than where i'm at with
it now it started very much from an
ideological place i was you know very
much a lefty in high school and college
uh democratic party was you know to the
right of where my personal politics were
at the time and so the initial view was
we needed a third party for me because i
didn't fit in the democrats i thought
that they were too centrist to moderate
and all of that um that has largely not
been something that i have believed
for probably like six or seven years at
this point but actually andrew working
on your presidential campaign is really
kind of what drew me in a different
direction
where a lot of the people that i was
speaking to who supported you who were
from the right side of the political
spectrum made some really good arguments
that i didn't have good responses to and
so i recognized that
these ideologically rigid parties that
kind of tell you what you need to
believe
are not
fantastic for this country and they're
not fantastic for us because not
everybody fits into these neat little
buckets so rather than try to come at
this from an ideal ideological angle at
this point i really think we need a
third party because we need to show
americans that there's another way to do
things you find your shared values you
build off of them you talk with people
who disagree with you you find
compromised positions that work for the
different people in that party
if you showed up to like a party and
every single person just had the exact
same ideas of what was fun and
conversation was just yeah i agree yeah
i agree it'd be a terrible party and uh
so why do we take that with our
political party and then secretly hide
you know the uh the views we have that
don't fit neatly into the uh the buckets
that they've defined for us so
you were with me through the
presidential and then when the forward
party
was getting started you've been carrying
really the the heaviest
uh operational
day-to-day responsibility while i was
running around being like hey guys
forward party we need it we need it uh
and then at the end of last year we
had conversations with two organizations
the serve america movement and the renew
america movement no relationship to each
other i joke even though they have the
same middle and last names uh and then
we had this convo saying hey
we should work together you know what
maybe we should go another step and
actually combine forces and
turn our organizations into one
organization
uh when we started having those
conversations how seriously did you take
the possibility that seven months later
we actually would do something that's
nearly unprecedented in
politics which is join forces uh i very
much thought that it's what we needed to
do and i very much thought that there
was almost no chance it would actually
happen because as you said it's it's
unprecedented you know ram and sam i've
come to respect the people who work over
it there but the starting point was very
much you know
different ideological positions and uh
that's just not how america thinks about
how you form a political organization or
political parties at this point so uh
you know the the new party space is just
littered with the corpses of all of the
failed attempts out there because this
is really really hard to do
and everybody tends to try and define
their own lane and not move forward with
it the two of us talked about this the
only way we can really make any headway
here is if we start to consolidate
instead of like everybody having you
know five hundred thousand dollars to a
million dollar budget we need to bring
all of that money all of those people
all that energy all those volunteers all
those millions and millions of americans
who really don't want to be a democrat
or a republican anymore but don't have a
landing pad a
new home that they can go to we need to
get all those people together
but you know we were still talking with
groups that we have some ideological
differences about so i didn't think that
it was likely to happen plus in politics
you know everybody's a politician and so
there's a lot of politics that are going
on behind the scenes but you know
getting to work with everybody over at
ram and sam has been fantastic because
everybody over there is really really
aligned on the same mission that we are
which is saying the country is broken
the two existing parties are taking us
in the wrong direction and trying to get
us to hate each other and if you get
down to it there's really just a ton of
stuff that we agree on you know you take
some of the the more controversial
issues out there say gun control i think
we can all agree that we want fewer
suicides and we don't want our kids to
be scared at school so let's start there
and then let's talk about the different
solutions that we want to propose and
find compromised positions that we can
all live with and move forward to make
those things happen and then make sure
that it's working that you know there
are fewer uh suicides by a gun there are
fewer school shootings and all of that
and if things were trying aren't working
let's try something else but we can't
really do that if half of the country is
yelling at the other half and failing to
agree and thinking that they're awful
human beings who are our enemies and
we've got to defeat them in order to
move america forward that's you know
we're a democracy if you hate half of
the country and think they're the enemy
the whole thing's going to collapse and
that's that's where we're headed so it's
been great working with uh with ram and
sam to really kind of find those common
values that we all share and bake that
into
the new ford party and find the way
forward with them yeah you're as logical
as the day is long matt which i think is
a common component of some of the early
forward party builders and members you
studied
was it chemistry or biology in college a
little bit of both biochem look at that
that's why i could have smashed those
together uh you then went to law school
which also tends to reward
logical thinkers one reason i'm so
excited about what we're doing is that
we are bringing together different
tribes different groups uh as long as
you can agree and one of the reasons why
i was very very pro
this combination of organizations
happening is i was like well we're
trying to unify half the country or 60
of the country so these are people who
are incredibly mission aligned where
they want to give americans a voice they
want to
rejuvenate and modernize our democracy
so i might not see eye to eye with them
on everything
but we can
completely work together on the most
important things but i found getting to
know them as you said really really
positive and delightful
and people who work in the third party
space
tend to be very very principled and
patriotic because there's no
real rational incentive to do it and
that's one thing that pisses me off
sometimes when people like oh like going
into the third party space like you must
be really full of yourself and are you
like are you kidding me like everyone
who's full of themselves like stays in
the two-party system because that you
know they'll get uh stroked on a regular
basis
[Laughter]
so when did you come to the conclusion
with ram and sam you're like you know
what i think that this merger is
happening and it's going to work there
were a lot of moments along the way
where there were various you know
breakthroughs or
moments where a little bit of trust was
built here or there but i think the
clearest moment um and you were in the
room for for this one andrew was uh when
we all got together and had um had a
look at a document that we'd been
working on a little bit behind the
scenes for a little while that really
laid out the values and principles that
brought us together
when we presented this for the first
time to the broader group it was very
much under the auspices of this is a an
early draft we're going to have to
revise we're going to get input from
everybody here
if there's language in here that you
don't feel comfortable with that's cool
we can still update it and everybody
looked at it and jess was like no that's
right that's exactly what we stand for
that's what brings us together
and the fact that the core values
underlying what we're trying to do here
were just so easily agreed upon by
everybody not that hard work didn't go
into defining it but once it was on the
page it was so easily agreed upon and
everybody really saw themselves in
something that
could have been quite controversial that
was the moment where i was like okay
there is a very very real path forward
here
and that also happened at a time when
you know we were we were getting
together and for the third or fourth
time as a as a wider group and uh you
know really starting to form the
friendships and bonds that you need that
trust that you need in order to kind of
come together on something like this so
these two organizations that we're
joining forces with one of them they're
actually both essentially
offshoots of
moderate republicans who saw the rise of
trump and said okay this is not cool
this is not for me this is not my party
um so the serve america movement has
been working in various states to get on
the ballot it's on the ballot or
recognized in four states which means
that forward parties now on the ballot
are recognized in four states ta-da look
at that got there quick uh and then the
renew america movement was co-founded by
our friend evan mcmullen and miles
taylor who will be on the podcast
shortly
uh to try and
make the republican party actually
principled and moral but they have
concluded that that's not happening and
so that a third party is the the right
path uh and the great thing is that
forward party people think of us as
coming
um from the left of the democratic party
which is factually accurate uh i was a
dem um and then sam is kind of down the
middle uh ram is like a
you know a little bit from the
republican party but this is truly the
big tent coalition that so many
americans have wanted where they say
look we can disagree on some things but
we can agree on the fact that we're
americans
we care about this country we can
uh work things out
we can respect each other enough to
respect election results
so
so these are
um so these are the orgs that we're
joining forces with uh they each come
with very very talented uh leaders and
operatives uh some of whom we'll hear
from
but it's an awesome awesome group uh and
these these folks are true
patriots trying to do the right thing
kudos to everyone involved particularly
you matt because you shepherded this
through more than anyone and you're
still leading the effort
people are going to get to know other
uh folks from the other
orgs that now form forward um i will say
too that
we're not done we're just getting
started um so as of this announcement
we are the third biggest political party
in the country uh by resources not by
ballot access or those other things that
we do have
volunteer
chapters in every state in the country
uh we think that we're going to thank
you for everyone who's part of that and
if you want to join please do go to
forwardparty.com and just find your
state chapter we are going to be
recognized or on the ballot and we think
about 15 states by the end of this year
30 by the end of next year and then
shooting for all 50 by the end of 2024
so let's talk through some of the big
operational goals of ford so now we
we've got this
multi-million dollar organization our
combined budget is
approaching 8 to 10 million
now which is really significant
uh we have again
uh volunteers in every state uh
thousands and thousands of donors
regular donors which we love so thank
you everyone uh
out there
uh so let's talk about what the heck
we're gonna do so there's the ballot
access piece and your legal background
is helpful because it turns out that
there's a lot of uh
lawyering involved in my conversation
last week with matthew ho
kind of indicates some of what faces
third parties um we're launching this
national tour including culminating in a
national convention next year so anyone
who wants to be a part of that you
really should sign up so that we can
build this thing and then you can come
to the convention and be part of history
new tour is launching in houston texas
on september 24th
uh but there are a few things that we're
going to be doing in the here and now in
communities including starting with the
506 000 or so locally elected officials
about 20 percent of whom are
non-partisan county execs and city
council members and village officials
some of them are uncontested some of
them are unpaid so you know people
hopefully are doing it for for good
reasons we think we can get to
thousands
of elected officials
by the end of next year
in part because there are functionally
thousands of independent officials right
now
and we go to them and say hey would you
like to join forward now you'll have
volunteers a mailing list you'll be one
of the leaders you can come to the
national convention whereas right now
you have none of those things we think
we can get hundreds and thousands of
takers pretty quickly yeah and if you
think about the elected officials that
you can vote for that actually have an
impact on your life it's you know not at
the federal level they go
you know down to dc they're in the house
they're one of hundreds of voices uh
can't really do much for you locally but
the board of ed that determines you know
what your what your kid learns the most
is fixing the potholes and making sure
that speed bumps are in the right places
and making sure that your community is
you know safe um so those are those are
to us the more impactful races that's
where we want to get involved that'll
help us train up a new generation of
leaders that will also help us really
get involved in the communities one of
the things that i heard from someone
during this whole process that i thought
was really smart was the two existing
political parties
view your vote as like
step one give us your vote and then we
will do stuff for you and then they
don't do anything because they'd rather
get into fights so that they can tell
you to vote for them again so they can
well they don't have to do anything to
keep their job uh you know like uh
there's no meaningful competition in 90
of these races but continue what i heard
that i thought really needs to inform
the ethos of what we're doing as an
operation is vote should be the
downstream effect of the party getting
involved in the community and helping to
improve it so you know outside of the
elected officials we also are looking to
engage with civic leaders in different
areas uh people who head up churches
volunteer organizations you know like
the local ambulance corps the local fire
department really going in and talking
with those people to tell them what ford
parties all about because
we believe that the whole purpose of
political power is to make people's
lives better not to make our lives
better but to make other people's lives
better and we come together our lives
are categorically worse
[Laughter]
i mean the vast majority of americans
would agree that we're heading in the
wrong direction and yet we keep on
voting for the same two options i think
there's a definition of insanity out
there that kind of
goes in that direction but yeah we like
as forward party we just want to get out
there in the community figure out how to
help the different communities um this
was something andrew that kind of sprung
up from the yang gang on the
presidential of so many of the yang gang
chapters or just go out and clean up a
park or clean up a river or you know
engage civically in the community yeah i
would love to make sure we do something
concrete and real in communities so that
win or lose a race it's like well you
did something good
and the goal like you said should be
doing good stuff not
trying to win various races all of the
time though i think we're going to be
able to win our fair share pretty
quickly in part because the two parties
are just so
weak and decrepit in
so many communities even in in a
community they're supposed to be
um very very present in you get there
and like no one likes them it turns out
i mean like that this thing is so ripe
for change
and
we want to make it a positive change not
a terrible change and in my opinion
terrible changes
are coming unless we kind of try and
beat them in the foot race
[Music]
but then you do have congressional races
that we can
play a role in as early as this november
and people who've been paying a lot of
attention i'm going to to go through a
few of the big races and see what you
think
so from for me some of the highest
priority races this november right now
that forward party can help with evan
mcmullen running for u.s senate in utah
and democrats aren't running a candidate
in that race so we have a chance to
defeat trump-endorsed incumbent who is
literally texting mark meadows on
january 6 being like how can i help i
mean
like that guy versus
evan whose true blue patriot
spent a decade overseas as part of the
cia trying to defend the country
ran for president in 2016 as an
independent as an anti-trump measure
so evan mcmullen in utah we have to help
him win he could be a fulcrum in the
senate as early as january of next year
lisa murkowski in alaska who voted to
impeach trump
and is now
being challenged by a trump-endorsed
candidate as per usual uh kelly chabaka
who let's say would not be your favorite
u.s senator
she's i mean you know you can imagine
some of these trump indoors candidates
are um pretty bad and kelly is i'd say
worse than the norm so that like lisa
murkowski winning is a huge deal
both uh for the here and now but also
because her chances of getting back into
office are almost entirely based on the
shift to open primaries and ranked
choice voting that we're championing
around the country the last poll i saw
said that lisa murkowski
was going to win 52-48 in the final
round of ranked choice voting after all
the other candidates get eliminated
except for her and chewbacca
so
uh that one's going to be razor close
yeah that's going to be super close and
getting
reform-minded people who i think at this
point in alaska you have to be if you're
voting for murkowski she's getting a
really wide coalition built together
it's going to be particularly important
because the
the republicans up in alaska have said
that if they retake you know the state
house there's a good chance that we lose
open primaries and ranked choice voting
up there and that would be boo that
would be catastrophic so you know we we
need to make sure that those reforms
don't get rolled back up there because
they are kind of proving how powerful
they are and you know i would say that
the fact that um the the political path
the political parties in power in the
states where these reforms are happening
are fighting against them so strong both
parties you know nevada the democrats
are going against it up in alaska the
republicans are going against it i think
that should tell you that uh it is
something that could actually threaten
the status quo threaten the current
power structures they wouldn't spend a
lot of time and resources trying to
fight something if they didn't think
that it could impact them and that's the
third big
race so to speak in november uh is the
ballot initiative in nevada
that
shifts them to non-partisan open
primaries and ranked choice voting which
as you said the democrats are now
fighting tooth and nail uh apparently
they spent seven figures trying to
discredit and fight it already
it's going through
um now the question is
will it pass in november
i heard polling that said that 60
percent of nevadans when presented with
the question hey would you like to vote
for whomever you like uh in in the
primary shockingly a majority of them
want that 60 want that but that's before
the democratic machine comes out and
scares the [ __ ] out of everyone and
probably spends millions of dollars
which typically happens in these ballot
initiatives
uh so there's a lot on the line uh
in in that state because if this ballot
initiative gets defeated it's going to
be uh you know if it if lisa murkowski
wins in alaska and this thing passes in
nevada it's going to feel like this
reform is sweeping the nation um but if
uh those two things don't happen then
it's going to seem like uh we're stuck
in the mud yeah absolutely and you know
there's a ton of great work going down
in nevada but
my money uh
pulls things in a certain direction so
we'll see what happens when all that
gets down there the thing that angers me
the most is when people are arguing
against these reforms especially ranked
choice voting which we've heard coming
out of
uh nevada now is that it's too
complicated like people are smart people
in this country are smart they can
figure out how to rank things that they
like that's not a high bar so uh to me
it's just it's a little infuriating that
apparently our elected officials think
so little of us that that is the
argument oh
you know you know that's a pharmacical
rationale matt the democratic party of
nevada literally uses rank choice voting
in its own operation so they know that
it works uh they just needed to come up
with some [ __ ] uh because their
consultants told them hey this is bad
for us so like fight it and then they
can't just come out and say the truth
which is like we're against this because
uh we think it introduces uncertainty
into our closed system and we dislike
competition so let's try and kill this
measure they can't say that so then
they'll say oh it's confusing
discourages minorities even though that
that by the way flies in the face of any
evidence the the political consultants
come in you know for the win again with
the recommendation that the argument you
should make is hey people you're too
stupid for this like it's just it's it's
kind of ridiculous to me some of the
advice that that gets uh injected into
these things and it's one reason why you
need a genuine third party is that there
are a lot of
uh folks who want these things and both
the republican the democratic party are
going to fight it wherever it hurts
their interests in that state uh you
know and it is one thing that irritates
the heck out of me is that there are so
many democrats who are like oh you know
we're fighting the
authoritarians and like anything that
distracts from us is like it's like well
let's play this out for a second
first
do you really think it's realistic that
you can defeat
the republicans in every race from now
until the end of time in a country where
88 of americans think we're on the wrong
track like that's your plan and so
you're going to yell at anyone who's
going to do something else because like
you've got this i mean and by the way
when someone comes along with an
intelligent
pro public interest reform then you're
going to spend seven figures on fighting
that you're going to get kick matthew ho
off the ballot because you think that
helps you you're going to elevate
extreme
republican candidates in the primary
like doug mastriano because you think
it's a better race for you it's like i
mean talk about uh against the public
interest you're like these people are a
threat to democracy let's spend millions
of dollars boosting them and make it so
that they actually get to the general
because like that that's i mean you can
see the logic in this perverse two-party
system it's like well i want a
quote-unquote more beatable opponent i
want a weaker opponent but
you're playing with fire yeah and i also
think that you know with two political
parties as we have now
obviously both parties believe that the
other one is worse for the country like
that's just how you you'd be a democrat
if you thought the democrats were better
for the country so you're not so you're
a republican and those are your only two
options but i think that oh yeah
how many times do forward party members
get accused of being
republicans because we're not democrats
i mean that's like freaking every 10
seconds yeah yeah and um you know
meanwhile the majority of the country is
independent yeah
even the republicans and democrats who
are still in the parties are uh not
particularly happy with those parties i
think the numbers are hovering in like
bouncing between 60 and 80 percent which
sure it's over 50 but if 60 of your
party thinks that you are terrible if 60
of your group thinks you're terrible
you're probably not a great group to
begin with so you know maybe maybe look
at yourself for a little while um but i
also think that having the two-party
system
that we currently have with the two
parties we have really makes both
parties
kind of end up in a bad position where
since the other party is
existentially bad for the country
anything you can do to beat them is okay
and that's how we end up in these
situations where the democrats are
elevating just
republican candidates that would be
completely unacceptable completely
unqualified completely all of that
because of course we should do anything
we can in order to win not even
recognizing that you've now first off
put the country at risk of those people
getting elected but second off you're
now just you've lost your moral core
you're not actually fighting for what's
best for the country anymore i feel like
the the country as a whole has kind of
lost that moral core the parties have
lost that moral core and we really need
to take some time together to define
that again so that we're operating
within the bounds of creating a good
place to live rather than just not
letting the other party take us in a
direction that we view as horrible well
i think this is the darkest part of the
two-party system matt which is that
increasingly what happens with people
families and communities totally
irrelevant politically
uh because hey you're stuck with us in
this blue area or this red area so i can
screw up or not screw up and it doesn't
really matter we have a re-elect rate of
94 as incumbents because we've carved
the country up like a turkey
and you can't get rid of us um and so
when someone comes to me and says like
hey you know my town's busted my
neighbors are addicted to drugs my kids
schools are closed you look at him being
like well
doesn't really matter because you can't
really do anything about it
and we don't actually understand how to
do anything about it as a political
party
because all we know how to do is
talk about how the other side's bad
and argue and that's our set of
incentives
we're essentially a bunch of
communicators
and inflamers
and what happens in your community
doesn't matter i can't tell you how many
political figures who speak in this
language and like no one actually cares
about what's happening on the ground in
real life
uh to people and families has just
become an elite communications
competition
uh as opposed to anything that's going
to change people's lives for the better
yeah one of the things that uh somebody
who works here at ford brought up that i
thought was really interesting uh is
that you know you go back 30 40 50 years
the number of coms staffs in any member
of congress's office you know single
digits one two maybe three
columns professionals now it's like
fifty percent or something ridiculous
like that i forget the actual number but
as you said most members of congress at
this point are
primarily
media figures and theater performers and
they're not legislators
a member of congress said to me
that if you are
in congress
and you're in the minority party you're
essentially a piece of furniture uh like
you're not consulted on anything you're
never gonna pass anything so what do you
do if you are full time you're like okay
i have to
elevate my political profile so like let
me try and figure out how i'm going to
do that even in a world where
i'm certainly not going to pass anything
meaningful yeah so maybe i'll propose
some messaging bills and say like oh
like i stood on this i fought for this
maybe i'll try and get on cable news
like that that's the coin of the realm
yeah and i think this also goes back to
something we were talking about a little
while ago too
with the parties have kind of
established their policies as the
defining features of themselves and so
if they're wrong about one of those and
they actually do manage to implement
something and it doesn't work out you
can't move around from that because
you're defined by that policy so like
what are you going to do now or you're
just going to keep on doubling down and
saying oh well you know
the problem is we didn't invest enough
resources in that or the problem is that
the other party sabotaged it or whatever
and then you end up just kind of
doubling down on failed policies instead
of saying like hey we tried this it was
wrong but what's really important to us
is that our communities are safer so
instead of going in this direction even
more let's reevaluate it let's find
other ways to make our community safer
and let's move in that direction and
that's where i think you really need
ideological diversity in these
conversations because other people are
going to have good ideas that you
wouldn't think of based on your own
background like there's plenty of areas
out there where based on my background
uh i would put forth certain ideas that
would be terrible probably like i'm not
i'm not a policy expert i'm not the
person who you should put in charge of
all the policies in the country because
i've got my biases and if i'm not having
them tested by other people or
challenged by other people if i'm not
hearing ideas brought up by other people
it's going to be wrong you get this echo
chamber and that's how you end up kind
of where we are now in the country where
the two parties just can't believe that
they are wrong because there's nobody in
the room saying we might be wrong
because everybody just agrees with each
other or gets cast out if they don't
so we've talked about the local
officials very exciting we talked about
some of the congressional races there
are others opportunities in november
that we can get into right now um but
then there is the big elephant in the
room 2024. what the heck is going on so
i want to uh discuss for a moment
something you have not heard matt but
it's going to be fun and exciting
i had dinner with a very very
significant uh
philanthropist
last week
who said that she sat in on and managed
actually i think she funded them
a number of focus groups
for groups
of
obama
trump
biden voters
the genuine swing group they voted for
barack obama in 2012 donald trump in
2016 and then they said screw that
joe biden in 2020.
this group comprises approximately six
percent of the electorate which in this
narrowly divided country is going to
decide most any election i think people
sense it you know you get six percent
swinging one awareness that's like 20
million voters yeah tens of millions of
voters so these focus groups had a
number of insights um these people are
very very upset about how things are
going right now they're they're really
not enjoying
this administration shall we say they
were asked to describe each party in one
word
uh and they actually pretty quickly
coalesced around one word for each party
what word do you think that they
used for the democratic party
ineffective
preachy okay that makes sense too what
word did they
come upon for the republican party
i i don't know what this podcast is
rated so i don't know what type of
language i'm gonna use what do you use
here uh it's it's it's rated adult but
the word was crazy okay i was gonna say
that [ __ ] was where i was going
yeah
yeah that i think batshit was right
there so i i think that
these swing voters are on to something
with both these parties they were then
presented with a choice saying you have
to choose
either preachy or crazy
and which do you think they chose i am
gonna say that they went with crazy
they went with crazy by an overwhelming
margin
90
plus which was mildly surprising when i
heard this but they they really really
detest preachy
they don't like crazy but that they're
the they'll choose it if they have to
people don't like being talked down to
or condescended to i think like that's
kind of i was bringing up the criticism
before of the people are too stupid to
figure out rank choice vote and kind of
the same thing like there's just a whole
lot of talking down to the american
people instead of just leveling with
them out there so that makes sense that
group's also interesting to me because
um you know we've talked before about
kind of the the obama trump voters
because you
had a decent number of them supporting
you in the the presidential i think the
way that you categorized them made a lot
of sense of they
were banking on change like obama
promised change trump promised change
they didn't have their lives going in
the right direction and then
you know they voted that way but to vote
for biden at that point suggests that
there is a level of change biden was
changed in 2020 that is true you know
biden was the change he was like okay
this isn't working let's let's try the
other horse
um but they are very very ticked off uh
and a lot of these folks
um
are
struggling uh with some of their
day-to-day financial
constraints and inflation is really
hitting them hard so they are very very
upset about what's going on
now the 2024 field
i think it's going to be trump of the
republican party
um there's a lot of noise about desantis
i don't think desantis decides to risk
his entire political future by going up
against trump in a death match he can
easily just coast for a cycle
and uh wind up in a great place he's a
young guy he's got plenty of time and i
think on the other side if trump is
running and then joe biden says i'm
running then the democrats will fall in
line pretty quick even if there are
concerns about his age and there are
some people who are very very
unenthusiastic
so right now the most likely matchup
remains trump biden ii
uh despite the fact that 58 percent of
americans don't
want that match up
uh don't want either of those men to be
president
in 2025
uh their combined age will be 159 at
that point it would be a visible
manifestation of just how
stupid and broken down the two-party
system is where you're like wait a
minute in a country of 330 million
people we're choosing between these guys
again
and they're four years older and uh
creakier i mean like this would really
be insanity
but guess what america like insanity is
still the most likely outcome
um and so a lot of people
look at forward party
um and they just reflexively think
presidential race because that's the way
they're programmed
um they're programmed to say like oh the
only reason anyone would get into third
parties would be if they're going to run
for president now we're not about that
we're about solving the country's
problems giving people a real choice
changing and improving the mechanics
changing the incentives within parties
uh there and we're here for the long
haul
that said
uh the country is not doing well uh the
field in 2024 could be completely
unacceptable to tens of millions of
americans
and we may be able to improve on that so
i want to present a vision of an
independent third-party
presidential nomination process where we
get people of diverse points of view and
backgrounds and say what you want to run
for president we will give you a fair
shake you can make your case the
american people and guess what a
political party can nominate
candidates
any way they want there is nothing about
starting in iowa new hampshire there's
nothing about ignoring major population
centers there are huge swaths of the
country that have not had any meaningful
input into presidential
nominations
their entire lives like you know for
uh multiple generations um so imagine
being able to participate in a real life
vital presidential primary
on your smartphone and then have your
vote be verified a few days later
um when a postcard arrives or maybe you
get a text message and it gets matched
your phone number gets matched up to
your public records but there are ways
that we can actually show america what
democracy can mean
and then come together behind a unity
ticket or a third party presidential
campaign that genuinely reflects the
desires and will of the american people
as opposed to someone who's just
managing to trudge along because of
seniority within a broken two-party
system
[Music]
there's a lot of people out there as you
noted who just structurally are kind of
cut out of this process
quite a bit
and if you think about the process
itself
uh you know i i think a good
proxy for this is the debates because
that's kind of the most visible part of
the the presidential selection process
think about how bad our debates are
these days i can say with authority
they're bad
i mean it doesn't have to be that way
we've had we we literally have had
debates presidential debates in this
country that we still talk about to this
day
like you know you go back to the 1800s
and we're still you know hearing about
lincoln's debates so there are better
ways to do these things uh it's just not
going to happen in the the current
system so you know we've got a we've got
to break out of that i think
you know we've talked about this the
media is talking about it at this point
there's a bunch of people who are
looking at it there's going to be
independent candidates for president in
2024 there's just way too many people
who don't want biden trump for that to
not happen there's people out there who
have flirted with runs before who do all
who have you know put feelers out all
that stuff before there's politicians
out there who we know are you know kind
of posturing in ways or like you know oh
i'm not there
there are a number of moderate
republicans in particular who are
looking at running for president and
trying to decide whether they're going
to do so within a republican primary
which by the way they're going to get
shellacked
if you have three or four
moderate republicans versus trump they
all get crushed
because he still maintains loyalty among
two-thirds or so of republican primary
voters again your stupid primary system
in action and some of them are looking
at running third party also i mean with
this stupid primary system i think
people lose sight very easily because we
present the number like the support for
trump within the republican party
represent that as a percentage but it's
a dwindling number of people because
more and more people are leaving the
republican party to become independents
who stays in the republican party at
this point the people who think the
republican party is a good place to be
and so you know you're getting the the
people who are like yeah trump should be
our standard bearer as the ones who are
sticking in the party and you get the
other people leaving and so of course
trump's gonna come out of that looking
good because the other people have left
and they can't vote in the republican
primary since they've now left that
party and become an independent so it's
just kind of pushing it in that
direction oh well i'm the math guy man i
spent months and months campaigning in
iowa you know what percentage of iowans
participated in the democratic caucus
what percentage
6.4
um so if i'm sure the republican number
is not that dissimilar so you're talking
about like 60 of the republican primary
voters in one of these states it's like
you know
you're going to be looking at
probably
like
10 20
of people saying like yeah we love trump
and then you're like oh half the country
loves trump it's like no actually it's
just within the the weird republican
primary electorate in a particular
location
if you open up to the general public
then things change really really quick
particularly if you give people genuine
choices because right now there are
millions of americans who aren't down
with trump who will never vote for the
democrat
uh because they just
hate democrats
whatever reason think they're preachy
whatever you give them another
choice um then they'd be like okay i'll
sign up for that um and and the problem
is right now that they're they're stuck
like the entire country's stuck and we
are going to unstick them to use some of
my
earlier language the forward party where
we're coming to a town near you this is
the most exciting development in
american politics you're talking to the
co-ceo of the third biggest political
party by resources in the country today
growing enormously all the time
matt what are you most excited about
first thank you thank you thank you
again for shepherding a very very
difficult
uh
merger um across the finish line how
many meetings and calls do you think you
had it was
definitely time consuming and difficult
to figure out all the details but as
i've said before just fantastic people
at both of those other organizations who
have been great to work with and focused
on the right stuff you know focused on
how to bring us together rather than
focused on
trying to find ways to make this thing
fall apart so it's been it's been months
it's been hundreds and hundreds of hours
of work
but we're at a very exciting point right
now where
we have finally brought these groups
together we're moving forward we are uh
gonna make a massive change in this
country what i'm most excited about uh
in this
maybe this isn't the best thing to say
but i'm most excited like this when we
started this thing up um we were trying
to tackle two
parties that have just an unbelievable
number of resources behind them uh and
the more people you have the more likely
you can make that happen like i
we're all in this as you as you said
nobody's in the third party space
because they think it's going to be easy
or glorious or any of that stuff anybody
who's in here is doing it because they
think that it's the right thing to do
and with more people it's more likely
that we get the outcome that we want so
i'm super excited to be working with the
these groups of people really really
really smart dedicated principal people
in order to make it more likely that we
end up coming out of this thing with the
country that we want you're all those
things too matt smart dedicated
principled uh so thrilled to have you as
a partner and colleague in this effort
uh we're going to
make it so that people realize they have
actual choice
that you they we can do better
uh these two parties are so ripe i mean
think about every industry that has
changed in american life over the last
50 years and politics has been the
exception and people are getting more
and more
pissed off about it it's more and more
obvious that that these structures are
not 21st century ready
[Laughter]
that it's time
for an upgrade and you my friend are
helping to make that upgrade possible
i'm gonna leave you with the the call to
action how can people
help and get involved with forward party
uh i
i love this question because a lot of
the times people think that you need to
do it have hundreds of hours to dedicate
to this or be able to you know be a
state lead and spend 50 hours a week
doing anything or you know find a job
you don't just go out and do good in
your community and if people ask be like
yeah this is you know come learn about
the forward party this is what we're
about we're about making communities
better uh you've got five minutes
give us five minutes if you've got five
hours give us five hours of just going
to your community and making it a better
place and uh we got a ton of resources
put together by some really smart people
on our team particularly uh blair and
josh on how to get civically engaged uh
to me a leader is somebody who behaves
in a way that they would like others to
behave and so just go out and be a
leader be
do the things that you think other
people should do in your community can
go from there um i'm i'm gonna hijack it
a little bit right now andrew to to give
some shout outs to some of the
volunteers that people are doing it out
there please caesar in nevada yeah who's
uh going crazy on the final five voting
fantastic out there and he's gotten us
in touch with a lot of local leaders who
are you know just doing exciting stuff
leslie's holding down the fort in
florida heather and rick are in michigan
and texas we got a 14 year old high
school student named ryan who i don't
even know how much time it took him to
do this but he put together a list of 2
800 local newspapers for people to write
letters to the editor to in order to
make the case for the forward party uh
we've got zach and gina silas brandon
steve tina these are just some of the
people out there who are going above and
beyond to show their communities that
things can be better if we all just
believe they can be better
and as you said like up until now this
has kind of been there's only two games
in town but that's kind of crazy
considering how many people are
independents out there like if if we
just had the whole country put their
heads down and say like hey no judgment
like close your eyes lift your hand if
you want a new option we'd be in the
majority today
and yet
everybody's just been browbeaten into
accepting these two parties so let's uh
let's stop
letting them tell us that we can't form
our own group from our own party go out
there improve this country do things a
different way
because they are in the minority not us
so let's go out and act like that yes
let's activate the people the true
majority i couldn't agree with you more
just everyone listening to this just go
to forward party and try and meet
someone
in your community in your state because
you'll be blown away the the folks who
are
volunteering
in this movement are just some of the
most uplifting amazing people i've ever
met uh and it will make you feel better
about
the country it makes me feel better
about the country every single day thank
you matt
forward let's take the country there
appreciate the heck out of you my friend
same to you andrew i always always
appreciate talking with you your
perspective and uh as always thanks for
bringing me along for this crazy ride
you